-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-I tell you... (CHUCKLES)
...what a week.
First, Margot Robbie
gets snubbed at the Oscars,
then Taylor Swift gets booed
at the football game.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
If you know
a rich, blonde bombshell,
-give her a hug.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Yeah.
No, the only bottle blonde
who did good this week
-was Donald Trump. (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-He, uh... He won the-- (LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Yeah, he won the--
Now, he won New Hampshire.
I mean-- And, of course,
very gracious in defeat
as always.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
He... He... He beat Nikki Haley,
who was the only hope
of something to go past Trump.
No, that didn't happen,
so he's furious.
His whole speech
was about how furious he is
that Nikki Haley is staying
in the race!
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And I get it,
it breaks a lifelong precedent
where he finishes first
and the woman leaves.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Oh, I kid, Donald Trump,
it's all in good fun.
Uh...
No, I know he's gonna be--
You know, it's...
Boy, it's sad, it's--
The whole thing is over now.
There's not even a race
to follow,
but that was always fun.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And Trump
is beating Biden, you know,
now in the national polls
pretty strongly,
and, um, all my
Democratic friends are saying,
"Relax, it's a long time
before the election,"
'cause, yeah, that's what
Biden's whole card is,
-time.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
No, that's--
We gotta get used to it.
This is it, this is the race.
Biden and Trump,
the race is over.
This is bad news
for the country, I think.
Very good news
for people who build ramps
on debate stages.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
You know... (CHUCKLES)
-You know that, uh-- (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Bill Clinton... (LAUGHS)
Bill Clinton, uh,
has been out of office
for 25 years,
is still younger
than both of them.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I'm not kidding about that.
That is a true fact.
Their combined age
is 158 years old.
The first... The first debate
is gonna be
at the Museum
of Natural History.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Uh, well, I don't think...
I don't think there's going
to be a debate.
I don't think
either one wants it.
I don't want it,
you don't want it, let's just...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Because neither one of them
is really up to it.
They're starting-- You know
what's trending on Twitter?
Dementia Don.
-Because...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Because... (CHUCKLES)
-(LAUGHS) Because Trump...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...Trump was talking
about Nancy Pelosi
during, uh, January 6,
but he kept
calling her Nikki Haley.
-"Nikki Haley did this."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
He also referred
to the president of North Korea
as Rae Dawn Chong.
-I thought that was...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Yeah.
The other-- (LAUGHS) Yeah.
You know what else Dementia Don
said this week?
This is a direct quote,
I don't know what it means,
no one does.
He said, word for word,
"We are an institute
in powerful death penalty,
we will put this on."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
Even Biden was like,
"What the fuck?"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)